we begin with an American missile launch
overnight amid growing threats from
North Korea the test firing is meant to
show the capability of United States
nuclear deterrence the intercontinental
ballistic missile was launched from
Vandenberg Air Force Base in California
it traveled more than 4,000 miles to
natal in the Pacific Ocean Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson made his clearest
comments yet about North Korea he
appeared yesterday in a surprise
appearance at a State Department press
briefing for the very first time and he
floated an idea saying the Trump
administration is open to dialogue with
North Korea and it is not seeking regime
change we're trying to convey to the
North Koreans we are not your enemy
we're not your threat but you are
presenting an unacceptable threat to us
and we have to respond and we hope that
at some point they will begin to
understand that and that we would like
to sit and have a dialogue with them
about the future that will give them the
security they seek and the future
economic prosperity for North Korea
we're learning more about how North
Korea's recent missile test came
dangerously close to an Air France jet
the missile landed in the Sea of Japan
where a plane with hundreds of people
aboard had flown by just minutes earlier
Kris Van Cleave is here with new
concerns about the safety of passenger
planes Kris good morning good morning
Air France insists there was no danger
from the falling missile but the
relatively close encounter with a
commercial airliner is raising new
questions not just about North Korea's
future threat to foreign nations but its
current potential danger to planes in
flight
Pentagon officials say the latest
missile test by North Korea presented
the biggest potential threat yet perhaps
capable of hitting the US mainland as
far away as New York and even though it
was an unarmed missile it still puts
civilians in harm's way they absolutely
are creating danger to commercial
airspace at 9:55 Eastern Time Friday
morning Air France flight 293 took off
from Tokyo headed to Paris then about 45
minutes later North Korea launched its
missile which climbed to more than 2,000
miles into the air while the missile was
in flight so was the Air France jet with
332 people on board the planes flight
path took it about 100 miles off the
coast of Japan the same area where the
missile landed some 10 minutes later
Air France issued a statement saying
North Korea's missile test owns do not
interfere in any way with Air France
flight paths we constantly analyze
potentially dangerous flyover zones and
adapt our flight plans accordingly but
CBS News national transportation safety
expert mark Rosen Cerf says the global
aviation system isn't prepared for an
unexpected missile launch I don't
believe that air traffic control would
have the capacity to be able to warn the
commercial aircraft that a missile was
in its flight path
the u.s. responded to North Korea's
latest missile launch by conducting a
test launch of its own over the weekend
as well as a joint exercise with South
Korea and Japan on Monday president
Trump promised to hold North Korea
accountable it will be handled Japan's
ambassador to the United Nations says he
expects the organization to draft a new
sanctions resolution against North Korea
within days Charlie thanks Chris good to
have you in the studio